[Musik]
ich bin valerie niehaus und das ist
unterm radar die vergessenen nachrichten
2021 schlaflose nächte für millionen
deutsche der grund lieferengpässe auf
den weltmärkten die verantwortlichen die
globalisierung mit sicherheit auch die
fdp generell die da oben
das ist unser problem
also während in deutschland die angst
davor groß ist nicht genug einkaufen zu
können fehlen in afghanistan viel
wichtigere dinge zum beispiel
menschenrechte nach der machtübernahme
mitte august 2021 durch die taliban
wurde afghanischen frauen mitgeteilt
dass sie erstens nicht arbeiten und
zweitens zu hause bleiben sollen also
zumindest erstmal bis man sich überlegt
hat wie das praktisch funktioniert
frauen in jeder hinsicht zu
diskriminieren trotzdem aber einen
großteil der gesellschaftlichen arbeit
weiter auf ihre schultern zu legen im
september endete die schulbildung für
frauen außerdem bereits nach der
sechsten klasse und ihre bürger zufall
frauenrechte kommen erst in der siebten
dran in afghanistan ebenfalls nicht
lieferbar nahrungsmittel das
welternährungsprogramm der vereinten
nationen berichtet dass knapp 23
millionen menschen in afghanistan
bereits im november nicht mehr genug zu
essen hatten eine besserung der
situation vor der nächsten ernte im märz
ist nicht in sicht aber er was soll's
schon drüber anmeldung im stress in
zahlreichen deutschen städten bundesweit
mussten wieder millionen deutsche
schlange stehen für eine impfung doch
damit nicht genug statt biontech dem
hochleistungs impfstoff made in germany
gab es für die meisten nur lauwarmes
moderner
leute
das eigentliche problem ist doch ein
ganz anderes die impf ungerechtigkeit
auf der welt
kovacs schon mal gehört koubek steht für
co wird 19 werks ins global access und
ist eine initiative die weltweit
gleichmäßigen und gerechten zugang zur
vip 19 impfstoffen gewährleisten soll
koubeks wurde gegründet auf initiative
der weltgesundheitsorganisation who der
europäischen kommission und von
frankreich und konnte bereits etwa eine
milliarde dosen impfstoff an insgesamt
144 länder und regionen ausliefern je
gerechtigkeit leider nein denn bei
näherem hinsehen ist kovacs vor allem
augenwischerei gut gemeint aber
letztlich nur ein feigenblatt für länder
wie zum beispiel deutschland ungefähr so
als würde ich für 300 euro essen gehen
und dann dem kellner einen angebissenen
keks als trinkgeld hinlegen darauf den
ich vorher noch ein bisschen drauf
gewusst haben koubeks wird so schlecht
ausgestattet das erst etwa zehn prozent
der bevölkerung in armen staaten geimpft
sind aber schon 70 prozent in europa und
nein die schnackseln nicht lieber statt
zum impfen zu gehen die sind einfach nur
strukturell benachteiligt gegenüber
ländern deren wohlstand zumindest zu
einem teil auf columbia school
ist ein schwieriges wort für deutschland
kolonialismus beruht es ist eine
pandemie da ist das wie bei plötzlichen
druckabfall im flugzeug ja jeder kümmert
sich erstmal um sich
und dann gleich danach um seinen
nachbarn die kovacs lieferungen steigen
doch sicherer sand an gerade genau das
gegenteil ist der fall weil der westen
so fleißig impft werden die kovacs
lieferungen sogar noch kleiner auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent werden 25
prozent weniger ausgeliefert als geplant
und so kann in den afrikanischen ländern
nur jeder sechste wenigstens zum teil
geimpft werden während wir hier in
deutschland schon ausrechnen wenn wir
uns den nächsten booster in den arm
jagen
was soll's
newsflash zwei prozent der landesfläche
will die neue bundesregierung für den
bau von windkraftanlagen ausweisen
energiewende schön und gut aber das muss
doch auch anderswo gehen ja anderswo
riesenüberraschung die reichsten staaten
haben am meisten zur klima krise
beigetragen und die ärmsten staaten
leiden am meisten unter ihr die
reichsten zehn prozent der
weltbevölkerung und ja da gehören auch
viele von uns dazu sind für über die
hälfte der co2 emissionen der letzten 30
jahre verantwortlich wenn wir die
erderwärmung auf maximal 1,5 grad
begrenzen wollen dann hat jeder mensch
auf der welt nur noch ein klima budget
von 1,5 tonnen co2 pro jahr wie viel
verbraucht der durchschnittsdeutsche 8
tonnen und ja richtig die ganz reichen
verbrauchen am allermeisten und
verzerren den durchschnitt aber ein jahr
autofahren ungefähr 12.000 kilometer in
einem durchschnittsauto das sind schon
4,1 tonnen co2 mehr als das pro kopf
budget hergibt einmal von deutschland
nach thailand und wieder zurück geflogen
wie ich vor zwei jahren war sehr schön
drei tonnen doppelt so viel wie
eigentlich verfügbar und klar
irgendjemand ist immer schlimmer als man
selber und ohne politische regulierung
haben wir gar keine chance das problem
in den griff zu kriegen aber es ist
wirklich nicht so dass wir gar nichts
mit der ganzen sache zu tun haben leute
schönen abend noch